to be the hardest worker in the nba i've
never been around a player
somebody has fallen
a
arena worker has fallen at the other end
and you can see right now
not sure if she fainted or fell
but they are assisting her
[Applause]
and out she goes
you know i say it's an arena word it may
have been somebody else
because they quickly got her up and and
got her off in a hurry
did she
if she fail is there blood down there
oh okay i think we've been told
it was a protest and i think she was
writing something on the floor
maybe it was
i've seen so many reggie miller wendy's
commercials i don't know what i'm going
to do if i see one more
probably writing baconator down there or
something right that's exactly right
so whatever it was she is gone and the
graffiti or whatever she was doing on
the floor
is being wiped away there's nothing like
the energy of a live nba playoff game
these are not the playoffs this is the
play in but it has that feel of a player
it's a playoff game but the playoffs are
right around the corner and you can be
loud you can be the difference be there
and secure your seats at nbatickit.com
allie what do you see down there then i
know that wasn't you doing the graffiti
but what was going on it's worse than
graffiti i was just told by security
that she apparently had glue and she
glued herself
to the floor
and she refused to lift her wrist up and
i don't mean to laugh but this really
happened she glued her wrist to the
floor and they were trying to pull her
off and she was resisting trying to keep
her wrists glued down
it was a protest of some sort i'm
assuming
ally
i think that's a fair assumption i'll
get some clarity on the purpose of it or
maybe we don't talk about it again
depending on what the answer is i've
never seen that before this is the first
for me and i've been around the game
close to 30 years
it's paul george sneaking his way in the
paint for a closing shot reed got a hand
on it
it's gobbled up by jared vanderbuilding
quickly the wolves the other way led by